what is the catholic church
i would say it's the mystical body of
jesus so as i said before it's not an
organization if we do it that way we're
going to miss it it's got organizational
elements to it you know so i'm a bishop
i'm a i'm a office holder within the
church but the church is an organism not
a not an organization
so it's a organism
of interconnected cells as i said namely
all of the baptized gathered around
christ
in a mystical union
that's the church but there's buildings
yeah there's titles sure
uh because it matters itself
institutionally then but so are the sort
of
heavy things about that all have to do
with pride
yeah sure whatever sexiness of the
buildings yeah no whatever is corrupt in
the church of course it comes from pride
from sin and one thing i like about you
know the new testament is so clear on
that i mean paul is in his little tiny
communities so before there was a
vatican or dioceses or anything
apologies little tiny communities of
christians like in corinth and ephesus
you know
what's the one thing we know about them
is they fought with each other because
paul's always upgrading them and you
know telling them come on would you
people get it together and you know
who's bewitched you and
so from the beginning we've been
fighting with each other because we're
made up of sinners and uh
you know so but one thing we do in in
catholic ecclesiology is the official
name for the study of the church is to
talk about the treasure and earth and
vessels
paul's language again the treasure is
christ the treasure is is
is the love he's bequeathed to the world
that's the treasure that we have but
it's always held in these really fragile
vessels namely us
and so it's going to be marked by
corruption and stupidity and pride and
everything else
well nevertheless there's a hierarchy
there's titles and so on
if we remove pride from the picture so
the best possible interpretation of the
hierarchy that makes up this one
organism this living organism
what's the
what's the role of the pope for example
what is the role
of
a bishop
for example like what is the role of the
hierarchy in terms of the broader vision
of
christianity catholicism as a religion
i'm a devotee of this guy named johann
adam mueller who was a theologian early
part of the 19th century and he was part
of the kind of romantic movement
and he said the purpose of the pope
is to symbolize and embody
and draw together the unity of the
entire church
so he's the personal symbol of the unity
of the church who's a bishop the bishop
is the personal symbol of the unity of a
diocese
who's a pastor of a parish he's the
personal symbol of the unity of that
parish so he understood it not so much
organizationally as organically again it
was like um
what
that around which the pattern organizes
itself
and if you don't have that that unifying
figure the community will kind of
facilitate and you see that all the time
without headship we would say so it's
more symbolic and organic than it is um
organizational so symbols for community
but there's such
uh fascinating peculiarities to each
individual symbol
see there's different characteristics
that make up the different people they
have different
uh ways of communicating they have
different hopes and fears and all that
kind of stuff
what uh
if they're all symbols
what's the role of the
different peculiarities of those symbols
of being an inspiring uniter versus
maybe a stronger type of um
more judgmental kind of communicator all
that kind of stuff i mean
can you maybe speak to the human part
of this
of these symbols yeah well i i might
just shift to another image um of
shepherd so that's a classic biblical
image and as a bishop i walk around with
this thing called the crozier which is a
shepherd's staff right so it's the
symbol of the bishop's office and the
crusher though is a kind of um it's a
kind of in-your-face thing in a way
because it's got the
the end of it was meant to hold off
wild animals and then the crook part of
it was meant to bring sheep back to the
fold right so i walk in with that oh
this is nice look at the bishop coming
in but that's a kind of in-your-face
symbol that i'm here to defend the
church against predators and i'm also
here to draw people in who are wandering
too far away
so that's okay i mean that's part of of
the role of the hierarchy and the pope
and bishops and and pastors pastor just
means shepherd right then the shepherd
of a parish so that's okay it's not like
just all you know sunshine and light and
what a pretty image
the the one who embodies the unity of
the community is also the shepherd
okay but again leaning on the human
thing yeah
the church is an institution
and i don't know if you've heard but
there is an element to power that
corrupts yeah and absolute power
corrupts absolutely as the old saying
goes
um
let me ask you something else that came
up on the reddit uh ama yeah
churches and the prosperity gospel and
yeah you've mentioned
that you may not be a fan
what are your views on this and what are
your views in general of money and power
corrupting the heads of these
institutions uh i don't like the
prosperity gospel because uh the gospel
is about
jesus journey into
radical self-forgetfulness on the cross
and he never makes a promise of earthly
um
well-being can you explain what the
prosperity gospel is yeah the view that
you know if i follow jesus and i follow
god with great trust that i will be
rewarded with
wealth and and position and status in
this world
it might be god's will but i got that
but you know aquinas said this that
let's say i look at a very sinful person
i said kind of he's got a great house
and he's richer than i am and all that
aquinas says yeah but what maybe that's
a punishment because maybe all that is
leading him away from god and actually
that's god's way of punishing him and
the fact that you don't have wealth in a
big house is actually a great gift to
you because now it frees you for doing
god's will so we we can't read
you know god's favor in worldly terms
i would say god's favor is am i
awakened to deeper love then i know that
i'm finding god's favor now god might
decide sure i want you to have this and
that i want i want to provide this to
you fine then i say thank you lord how
can i use it as an instrument of love
see
all the masters talk about detachment
and that's another reason i don't like
the prosperity gospel is though i'm i'm
getting attached now to all these
material advantages
and i'm even seeing them as a sign of
god's favor let go of all that you let
go of it and use it as a vehicle of love
so if you're rich the right question is
okay lord why did you allow me to become
rich so that what can i do how can my
riches be an expression of love if i'm
popular if i'm healthy
okay why am i popular why am i healthy
how can i use that for your good i'm
sick in bed i'm suffering
okay
lord how can i use that as an expression
of love
so i'd rather measure it that way than
through worldly success that's why i'm
against the prosperity gospel
okay
so there there's uh
don't seek worldly possessions but
whatever happens to you
good or bad seek how that could be used
to increase the amount of love in the
world right the image i i love for this
is the wheel of fortune which is a
device on a lot of the gothic cathedrals
and it's it's this great circle right
this wheel and the top of his is a king
and then it turns this way and the king
has lost his crown and the bottom is a
pauper and then over here is a king he's
a guy climbing up to power right
and then in the middle is a depiction of
christ
and the idea is very simple but very
profound that the wheel is life you know
it's sometimes you're up sometimes
you're down sometimes you have power and
popularity and prestige other times
you're losing it you're going down other
times you've got none of it other times
you're coming back up okay don't live on
the rim of the wheel it'll make you
crazy every point on the rim of the
wheel is a point of anxiety where you
should live is the center of the wheel
where christ is right because that's the
link now to the eternity of god that's
the point of love
where love can flow through you to the
world and then you can look at the wheel
you're a beatles fan right i think i
discovered that i love the beatles and
the song that always comes my mind when
i when i think of that image is john
lennon at the end of his life
so a guy that i mean rode the wheel of
fortune like crazy you know he was at
the top of the world in every way
and then beatles break up and he kind of
loses it and then he's at the lost
weekend in the 70s at the very bottom
when he died he was just kind of coming
back up again but
the song i always think of is watching
the wheels right i'm just sitting here
watching the wheels go round around i
really love to watch them roll because
i'm no longer riding on the
merry-go-round that's right out of the
medieval mystics that he's not riding on
the on the wheel he's just watching it
go round and round that's the point of
uh the greece called it apathea and the
latins called it uh uh in indifference
you know
not like i'm blase it just means i'm i'm
detached
from success failure
less success more success i'm detached
from that i'm sitting here watching the
wheels go round and round because i'm
not writing on it anymore the mystics
have always made that transition
you